I'm thinking to myself I'm like wait if
anyone's a match
[Music]
I'm a match
so now you start running that cycle
through your head you're like
this balcony looks
far enough
Ashton Kutcher reveals he once
considered jumping off a balcony to save
his brother's life he said that he
thought about jumping off of a balcony
right to end his life so his brother
would have a heart yeah and I mean and
you know the emotion between them and
you know them look at each other holding
hands was just remarkably powerful
Ashton appears on the premiere episode
of Paramount Plus's new health series
The checkup with Dr David agus alongside
his twin brother Michael who was
diagnosed with cerebral palsy A
congenital disorder of movement muscle
tone or posture when he was three years
old then when the Twins were in eighth
grade Michael Learned he had an enlarged
heart and had three to four weeks to
live unless he received a transplant and
it's like you're gonna go to your
brother
and then I'm like
what this is going and in hindsight you
realize they want me to see him because
they don't know where this is going the
brothers get emotional during the sit
down with Dr Aegis who is both Ashton
and his wife Mila Kunis's General
physician I think that his ethos as a
doctor in his bedside Manner and the way
that he makes everybody feel comfortable
he's
hands down the smartest person I ever
met and he just wants people to be okay
like there's no God complex behind it
there's no ego behind it he wants
everyone to feel safe and comfortable
well Ashton and Michael seemingly felt
safe and comfortable Ashton revealed
that when he learned the severity of his
brother's condition he went into
problem-solving mode I was like I'm
gonna figure out what the situation is
and I'm gonna figure out how to fix it
and I'm thinking to myself I'm like wait
if anyone's a match
foreign
[Music]
this balcony looks far enough to take
things Against All Odds Michael found a
match in 24 hours and received a heart
transplant and Ashton says his brother's
Health struggles gave him a special
appreciation for life when you have this
face to face with death at that age
you instantly lock into this so let me
do as much as I can while I can
because I don't I don't know when it's
gonna be over the values of where I'm
spending my time which tends to be with
my kids probably the biggest shift that
it took place and all that Echoes what
the dad of two told ET back in 2016.
we're home bodies like we do a lot of
sitting on the porch yeah uh that's
pretty good stuff you know we go we'll
go canoeing down the river go fishing or
you know really just hang out so whether
he's looking out for his twin brother or
sitting on the porch with his kiddos one
thing's for sure Ashton's all about
family
foreign